a weekend trip to the rock island's the
children are excited a fishing
competition is on the agenda the junior
angler event and for the first time
snorkeling here the children can see
biodiversity firsthand mollusks sea
cucumber starfish and many species of
fish palau is famed for its underwater
marine life it's quite important that we
protect what's in the biodiversity that
can be found in the rapids and
especially these protected areas where
we know different species use them as
for feeding areas and as well as a
nursery for a different for turtles and
fish the aquarium becomes a classroom
iveth o Carell explains why nature
reserves make sense she heads a project
aimed at convincing palau ins to take an
active part in protecting their marine
habitats the children flocked to captain
molly the project mascot he's a Napoleon
wrasse and here's a real one the fish is
on the endangered species list
so we selected the Napoleon wrasse
because it is found in the other
conservation area and we would like this
as a flagship species for our other
conservation areas within the rounds
because it is very important and we
still see them here in Palau where else
other islands in Micronesia in Guam are
in point bay they don't see them anymore
the rock island's are a few hundred
islands off palau former coral reefs
shaped by wind and water The Rock Island
southern Lagoon is a unesco world
heritage site but palau is biodiversity
isn't only underwater in some places on
Palau largest island bauble dub only a
single road cuts through the rainforest
an estimated thousand tree and plant
species grow here and some of them only
here palau isolated location in the
middle of the Pacific has led to flora
and fauna adapting specifically to this
environment like the rain bird so called
because it Twitter's just before a
rainfall the children in the school know
it well it's also a mascot named arm
Ella an enjoyable way of putting species
protection on a lesson plan
project leader and san jo says having
mascots to promote species protection
makes sense this one of the 12 and
Democrats of Palau and so protection of
the forest the end the biodiversity of
the plants within our forest it's also
protection of our mella so her part of
the campaign is that if you destroy the
forest you destroy my home and my
children's homes the women from northern
bubble Dog Island want to protect the
forest here they're collecting plants
which the later grow in a nursery while
doing so they're rediscovering some
species themselves what is normally
expected from people to interact with
the earth basically that has sort of
been lost and so by coming out here and
having them learn more about Klaus and
not just the names of the plants but
also the force itself it gives a lot of
sense of value then you can actually ask
them let's restore the native forest
and that's what the women here have been
doing for a good six months at first
there were only three of them many
others were skeptical now 25 women are
taking part they don't want to accept
that forest areas like this that have
burned down remain that way vegetation
is beginning to grow here again 72,000
plants are planned in all so they have a
lot of work ahead of them and the women
do it voluntarily with simple means
they're also erecting barriers against
the erosion that takes place when the
rain comes why don't we take a soil to
the sea and from there they cover all
the the bottom sediment covers and the
cells that are used to live under they
die the main rose a few kilometers
further down are already coated in
sediment but they can hold back only
some of the soil everything beyond that
is just going directly writing to the
reef and so what the communities
realizing is that the area that used to
be such an important area for them to
glean to fish is no longer a productive
brief
the women are changing their attitudes
and bit by bit they're convincing the
rest of the community we try our best
and we wish and we pray for how can we
are gonna be like a before the children
are too young to know what it was like
before but now they're learning that
when they go fishing they have to be
selected and use the right methods
because there's fishing in a protected
area the fish will later be returned to
the ocean we want to really convey to
the kids that you know there's protected
areas because they will be the sanctuary
front Fisher that can spill over so once
they spill over to the outsiders then
you can fish it so without those areas
then they'll be less fish for them to US
airways nine pounds Vince at 4.3 pounds
not all the children have caught a fish
by the end of the day but they have all
learned how important it is to protect
biodiversity